khiến cao điểm kiểm tra, sử lý môi lộ và gián lận thương mại,
lực lượng chức năng cao bằng vừa tu dữ lượng lấn hàng nha bộ không só hồn gốc.
Đoàn kiểm tra liên ngày ngôn chi cục quán lý thiệt trường tình cao bằng và phòng cạnh
sát kinh tế công an tình đã tiên thành kiểm tra đồ sốt hộ kinh dành VTC.
Tại sóng hạnh phúc, xá hoàng tung, vình hoã an, quá kiểm tra, lượng chức năng phát hiện
kinh dành cho phép 3 mít tương, nhìn chiến 3 mít tương, sản phẩm thực phẩm và 1 in 2 trăm bịch sế về sinh không còn hóa đơn,
chúng tôi chứng miền của nguồn sức sử.
Tung ra chỉ số hảng hóa vi phạm ước tính gần tảm ước lắm chự động.
Đoàn kiểm tra đã lập biến bản vi phạm hành chính, tạm giữ tòa mộ số hảng hóa để tiếp tục sắp miền,
làm gió và sử lý theo quy định của pháp lợp.
Chí cuộc quan lý thiệt trường tình cao bằng chỉ đạo các đổi quan lý thiệt trường tăng cường công tác kiểm tra,
bám sát tình gình thị trường, chủ động phát hiện, đấu tranh và sử lý nghiêm các hình vì đi phạm.
Qua đó, vóa phần bảo vệ quyền lợi chính đáng của người thương và sử vấn ổn định thị trường địa phương.